12 km de long entre la riche et
Chambray-lès-Tours 22 stations c'est le
descriptif de la seconde ligne de
tramway présentait ce mercredi matin à
la presse le tracé par le boulevard Jean
Royer et définitivement tacté la
mauvaise surprise c'est le surcoût du à
la hausse des taux d'intérêt à la
flambée des coûts plus 80 millions
d'euros ce qui porte le budget à plus de
500 millions d'euros le point sur le
calendrier de ce chantier titanesque
avec Sarago
sur les rails ce matin les différents
acteurs du projet ont révélé le tracé
définitif de la future ligne de tramway
interminus à la riche l'autre a chambré
en passant par tour et jouer les tours
le tout en 40 minutes les arrêts
desserviron des pôles sportives
scolaires et universitaires comme le
site Grandmont mais aussi les hôpitaux
bretonneaux et trousseau
des études menées depuis un an ont
finalement acté le passage par le
boulevard Jean Royer des nouvelles sont
à venir pour préciser la végétalisation
et les conditions d'insertion du tramway
nous avons travaillé aussi pour faire en
sorte que le trafic de transit qui
aujourd'hui est assez important puisque
c'est plusieurs milliers de voitures qui
passent soit supprimés pour ça on va
avoir un plan de circulation qui ne
permettra plus finalement la traversée
de ce boulevard de parents parts avec
des changements de circulation de sens
de circulation on conserve bien sûr
c'est l'accès aux riverains le
calendrier a aussi été clarifié
prochaine étape constituer le dossier
pour l'enquête publique d'ici un an afin
d'obtenir l'approbation de l'État les
travaux pourront commencer mi-2025
jusqu'à 2028 date prévue de
l'inauguration de la ligne je suis
vraiment très très heureux que en fin de
sa puisse redémarrer et pouvoir voir les
études et bientôt les premiers coups de
pelleteuse arrivés sur ce chantier vers
2025 au total le projet s'élève à 503
millions d'euros un coût supplémentaire
par rapport au budget initialement prévu
en raison de l'inflation